so first my background so this PhD is
not like Oh an expert machine learning
in machine learning of computer science
sorry I'm biologist so I worked in
biomedical research and I love I at the
time I didn't know how to code so it was
like bench science yeah by baiting and
stuff and then I don't Python at an
intensive boot camp and now i'm a
developer i guess and i recently started
this position as a data scientist so
what it means in my case is a mixture of
background in science research and
knowledge in software and web
development and a lot of time i ask
myself so what would I have done earlier
when I was working in the lab and I
didn't up out code now that I if I had
known how to code what would I have done
differently and so I have several ideas
of project and here i will present you
this project so it's a personal project
it's not something i did at work so
what's my idea so i added a psg comic to
illustrate this idea so as you must know
research scientists have to go through
bibliography it means that quite often
they have to read through all of the
articles available and find something
related to their area so either add to
avoid this kind of situation when well
someone already published what you're
working on so that's too bad and
something else is also it gives you more
background on your subject and can help
you to interpret your results and so
that's something that takes a lot of
time when a few years ago it was mostly
like we were mostly printing PDF but I
guess now people actually read on their
screen but a lot of people still I think
find that quite boring time consuming
and I was wondering if there's a way to
make it faster better
and so what I wanted to do was gather
information from scientific article from
different subcategories so here because
that's what I know better I will focus
on biology but gather information from
Ted fig article from different
subcategories and be able with a new
article to classify it in one of those
category so how did I plan to execute
this project and here's a chance to
explain my idea so i will have article
from one category that i'm calling a and
another one coin bit cold B and using
NLP i was thinking i will get the most
frequent terms on in these different
categories and then using machine
learning supervised machine learning i
will be able to build a classifier so
how did I actually do it so the first
step was to actually get those articles
to start with so if I want to analyze
data how do I get my data so I was super
excited because recently there are lots
of things happening in open science open
access so there I thought well I don't
need to worry about having to pay for
those article there will be available
Freddy online but the thing is well
there are lots of articles available for
free online but how do i actually get
them so where's the API I thought he
life science journal had an API but
they're saying it's not really while
they're using it internally for their
own thing and so the solution i found
was actually to look into one of their
github repository where they have piles
in xml formats so that's the easiest way
of identified so far so I get call this
repository
and try to pass this XML files using
beautiful soup there are some subject
for each article but sometimes there are
several of them and because I wanted to
have distinct classes I only look for
the one that had only one subject
attached and I chose the neuroscience
for one group and cell biology it's like
the two group that of them highest
number of articles so that's why I ain't
short on and then the second step was to
try and retrieve the most important
terms from those categories of articles
and fold that how new ha I knew how to
like write a simple script using
analytical engines in Python library and
try to implement the tf-idf model to
actually get those terms and here is
like easy example of how I implemented
that this so here I'm taking an example
text importing things from the NLT key
and jensen libraries then the first step
i'm using is so taken tokenization so
i'm breaking down these texts into small
elements lower casing it also removing
stop words which are considered to be
words that are don't carry much meaning
and removing punctuation so here the the
output for this example and then the
next step is limited edition ostomy
zation i showed limitation I yeah I just
chose this one and used tool from NL TK
to do it so it expected for example that
all the better will be changed to good
but it did not happen what I notice is
like words that worse plurals actually
came up single singular so it works but
there might be like a better way to do
it then in this step I'm creating oh
yeah so i'm using the bag of work and
using a dictionary from jensen library
and on this dictionary object that I
create I call the duck to back off word
function and this is what I retrieve so
I have a list of tuples and the first
element of the stupas is like the index
of the world in the document so in the
sentence here and the second is the
frequency of this world and and then
stop oh yeah I'm is done that step of
actually using the GF idea of model on
the back of world and associating on top
of the frequency of the world the the
proportion of the word in the world
document so first I only have the
frequency in this sentence and then I'm
also taking into account while I'm
talking taking into account the length
of the document and indent following
step i'm using the latent semantic
indexing model which as far as i
understand it takes into account the
meaning of these words and so I'm
retrieving we can see here it's been cut
but I can when I call the model function
I can give it a number of topics that I
want to retrieve and here i arbitrarily
chose to it with three topics for each
sentence and using on the other side
object I can reveal so the the topics
which is associated with this index and
and I'm actually what I chose to do is
not keep this frequency score and only
gather all the terms that are most in
button in a while here in that text but
for the article oh sorry
oops
yeah I think I was finished so still in
executing my plan and retrieving the
most frequent articles so then I knew
that I could use this script and I had
like tons of files article files so what
I did was well on one side I converted
all this XML while I fast them and
converted them to txt files and then I
thought I will build functions instead
of having a script so I could call this
function on this list of XML files which
is what I did so here I just loaded 9
get topic file where I'm actually so I
have most upwards that I used in my
example I kind of didn't know where to
stop because when I I tried this on an
example of a scientific abstract and I
didn't know when does this would
actually bring meaning to the text on
when does it bring nothing to the text
and but at some point I had to stop so
that's where I stopped and I also had
some other problem that i will talk
about later but basically i had to
replace the like greek characters in the
text and so here is how the function i
use which is like if you remember the
Scriptures before so it's just the steps
of the script so passing the text
getting the tokens the meditation bag of
words then trying to apply those to
statistical models and getting the
topics out of them so just the words and
not the score that is a link to it and
here is the function i will go which
basically cause each of the previous
function well after the other and so
from audiologic article i had so i pass
them and created directories depending
on the subjects and i'll put it the text
file in them so i'm looking in that path
for all this article
and creating a list and basically
calling this function oops here the
guitar pick function on that bath and
and I'm dumping everything in a JSON
file to just other way too well to keep
it for later for a second step so high
so I don't have that much data I think
that's because I chose to select article
that only belong to one subject so I
have less that 200 article for
neuroscience and less than 100 for cell
biology I guess we can discuss that
later and so that's the example of
things that are I retrieved phone
article so some things that seems most
and well sometimes obviously seem more
scientific than others but as I said at
somebody I had to stop trying to clean
the the text so here we come to the
third step of the process trying to
actually build the classifier and so I
chose to use scikit-learn which means
using numpy data structure and here is
like what i actually did so I had my
data output it to a JSON file so I'm
going through this JSON file here and
this is just an example so i have
neuroscience in what part and then side
cell biology and then i have like a
dictionary structure with the key being
so a publication ID that i found from
life science journal and and then the
value associated to it is like a list of
all the most frequent of our terms that
i got from this article and then the
next step was actually building numpy
array containing all containing all of
them
of my most frequent word for all of the
articles and we can see from here that
my ID was that for each cone will be
first all of the publication IDs then
the class it belongs to so class or
subjects I keep changing world sorry so
the subjects either neuroscience or
cellular biology and then as I decided
not to take the term frequencies I will
have just a 0 0 1 because I will have
for each column all of the words that I
found in all of those articles as most
frequent in all of these articles and
each row will be an article i will have
a 1 if this word is part of the most
frequent for this article or a zero if
it's not a i guess it's something that
could also be discussed other strategy
and so that's how it actually looks like
and so the dimension you can see that
there are over over two thousand columns
in this and over 200 and of rose I
wanted to look at the have a look at the
data but it's not well it's not really
pretty because I if I plot I don't have
like all of these dots because it's
binary data to give you an example I try
to plot a few of these terms as a using
a bar charts so here on the x-axis
they're just randomly chosen terms so
the first one is for example detected
then could because I know I didn't
remove it and all these words are from
the retreat from some articles and the
colors is the class they're going to so
either cell biology neuroscience so some
terms are almost equal affine in both
and sometimes some terms although it
means it seems to not bring my meaning
but they are only fine in one category
and not the other so at this point I
thought that maybe it was a good way to
go so maybe I should be able to add
classify these two subjects I still made
some kind of plot although it's not it's
not super informative but it's still a
good way to see the data so on the x
axis I have the term distinct and on the
y axis I have modulation and force it
just to see that force some terms like
modulation there they exist they are
only found in well in this data set they
are only fun in one type of articles of
the neuroscience article and well-known
the
there are most yeah they are mostly
finding your science article they are
not finding cell biology articles and
four but they are also absent in some of
the neural science articles with a
lighter red color here that's what I so
on and then for this term it's it's also
mostly found in one of the category and
not the other so I add as I said at that
point I thought like it might might be a
good way to go and going on to the
second step of actually building the
clave classifier with dolls data so i
tried to algorithm that I think are
amongst the simplest to implement so I
first I tried the naive Bayes classifier
which assume the Independence of the
features and in this case I kind of
assumed that the all the terms were
independent and it's also widely used so
I thought can be a good approach and it
is used in text that's the
categorization in classification so yeah
good way to go and it doesn't require
very large data set which is my case and
I tried I actually chose the bernoulli
knife based classifier as it's mostly it
is the one I'm mostly used in text
categorization and especially when the
data is not continuous and it's my case
so I have a binary data because I didn't
just again I didn't take the term
frequencies but only the absence or
presence of the world
so I'm using cyclotron and using the
test trend test weight function to
separate my data set into training and
testing set and yeah so using the this
model I'm doing the yeah i'm using the
brake function on the test and actually
trying to figure out so he's this model
actually performance on my type of data
and i thought one of the way to go was
looking at the confusion matrix so
that's what I did and so what I would
like to see obviously is to have hydro
positive which is not the case and out
of around 60 case i will have well
mostly on I will have so I'm not good at
looking at true neck and positive but at
true negative and I'm also oh yeah so
another way to look at the performance
is looking at the classification report
and also the accuracy score so only
looking at the accuracy score which is
down here it looks like well I'm not
sure but it seems like it's pretty
accurate and looking here more for at
the classification report and looking at
the two class so the 0 is for cell
biology and one is neuroscience um oh
yeah i forgot to to explain just before
but I transform the classes which were
so neuroscience and cell biology into
binary her so what one is now your
science & 0 is now cellular biology and
so the precision seems quite high so
meaning in that case that out of article
that
identify of as new asylums a lot of them
will actually be neuroscience article
and the other way around while the
recall when out of biology article out
of the biology article with only a few
ones will be classified as biology
articles so this seems good to classify
newest neuroscience article instead of
and not really the seller biology
article which i think is due to the fact
that there are much more neuroscience
articles compared to Scylla biology
article that's the second algorithm I
tested Kenya's neighbor also because
it's easy to employment using
scikit-learn and yeah so it as you know
it's a way to predict the label of a new
point oh okay from its neighbor and yeah
it's company is known to be
computationally intense nationally
demanding but in my case because I have
such a small data sets and I'm not
worried so in this site i'm dividing my
data set in the same way as I did for
the nave based classifier and I
basically seems to have roughly the same
kind of results I have an accuracy just
a little less and oh okay now I know in
this case I have better recall and
precision so yes it's not like show you
some results and after seeing well
especially yeah yesterday evening so
there was this workshop by Ellen and she
shone from the Cambridge coding Academy
on by dating models and so I thought I
will add this careful cross-validation
still using scikit-learn library and I'm
looking at so I'm during Italy iterating
through the randomizing of sampling from
2 to 20 times and looking at the
difference on the in the that means
scores differences between those two
models and so what I see is actually in
term of only looking at the accuracy the
naive bayes classifier seems to be more
efficient and yeah so the maximum but
the maximum of accuracy she seems to be
when the the training is done around 10
10 times so I just this is just me
trying to think oh well there is a shop
of shuffle function but I thought if I
do use the fitting function 10 times I
should have be at the highest accuracy
level and quite a low standard deviation
and I just tried again the Navy base
classifier on to run random article
they're not really random because I shot
them to be thinking they belong to one
or the other class and so what we can
see here is I all always retrieve the
class one which is new science which was
chose to have a higher precision and I
think it's because I have more data sent
more data for it so the first article i
tested for meats and I also find it as a
cell biology article but it turns out
the class fare predicted to be a
neuroscience article and the second one
on cerebral ischaemia which ok it says
neuroscience paper and it turns out to
be classified as a neuroscience paper
so I guess its own it's time so what's
one won't so I started out with this
project and I thought would be easy and
fast but then I spent a lot of time
trying to actually get data and cleaning
it and hence my second points unicode
hurts because i had all of these weird
characters that were keep coming up so
each time i was running my function i
had a unicorn code error and so yeah hey
to conquer than expecting and the
performance I don't know if I can say no
but it's to be improved obviously
because I'm when I have what I only
tested it with two article in the end
but yeah if all of my article comes out
as neuroscience article that I'm not
classifying anything and so in the what
next you may have I guess more
suggestion but I think one of my problem
is the quantity of data as well as the
quality so as I haven't seen any API or
any way to get a queen like JSON format
they turn anytime soon I'm thinking the
way to go would be maybe to scrub open
access articles in term of text analyzes
it might be better to use term
frequencies instead of just binary data
that i'm not sure what seems like way to
go is maybe using this word to vector
instead of the bag of world and
retrieving which I think lead to the
second point instead of using one world
have a vector of several words because
especially when I'm retrieving as
frequent um an adjective I want to know
which now is linked to two so I'm
thinking to get more meaning i should
have several worlds i'm not sure how
many will be more relevant on that
several world instead of only one
and yeah so yeah that's it and because I
just said what went wrong I want to say
what's good about it so for beginners
and also non beginners I think it's a
good thing to have like side project
personal projects which is a lot
different from work project were you
already have like usually a lot of data
although it's also not the quality is
not super good but it's also it's a good
way to learn and practice and yeah so I
encourage you and before you say that
you don't have time because we never
have time good solution is like me to
submit a talk and when it's accepted all
done yeah you have to work on your
project yeah that's that's me on twitter
and you can look at some code on my
github repository for this project
questions yeah so you a DJ
classification of articles and the
question is how you use the
specification in order to determine if
the article is worse you're reading yeah
my idea of worth reading is depending on
your interest and oh yeah so I forgot to
mention but when I'm saying this is my
oh wait one when I'm showing this shot
and saying like this is my plan of
action but it's like me simplifying the
problem at the like lower level like the
I have this idea but where can I start
and my idea was if you're interesting is
some things some specific subject then
huh that's how i will start telling you
if this article is interesting for you
or not and then I simply yeah so if your
tasties for example is on
like for me on cell death cell biology
cancer cells so that's this I will be
interested in those r AO medication unix
of logically and then all the same to
understand seems logical spot blower oh
that's so good now that's a good idea
for later i guess for now I'm just using
the text in itself and I yeah I even so
i just took their repository and there
were lots a world bunch of articles but
i don't know yeah their popularity well
that's a good idea yeah because yeah
obviously well obviously you might want
to read like the one that are the most
popular in URL you know thank you well i
have two patients and it's some 14 years
flavors which make is okay
I just try three neighbors five and 15
and 3 seem to give a better higher
accuracy so that's the one I showed so
let's say for the features if you make
an additional features using mobile
information to get places trying to
compete what are the most important for
tokens for each legs and then peaking at
risk easier hundred so you have two
places they have more compact
representation for your tastes and you
can check if you proficient performance
better or not and and easy let's say if
you apply you base your features are
indeed if idea we still straight forward
to compute the likelihood or we still
have to do some press relation because
with binary features it works well with
here at whittier idea to make it
something else I'm not sure I I thought
I will simplify again by not taking the
scar from the tf-idf but only using the
words themselves and saying if they're
there or not for each article so i'm not
sure but i would expect there will be
another layer of complexity
um Chester it's as much of the article I
that I could get yeah I didn't try no I
don't try it only so when I first the
XML I tried to retrieve as much as
possible which I think well depending on
what a life science the journal puts in
their repository but at least i'm sure i
have the abstract because the tag and
xml is abstract so is stress for one and
for the rest I see a lot of results for
sure i'm not sure if i have the
discussion but for sure I have abstract
I think introduction and results but I
just took all of it and wrote it to a
text file I didn't wrote the right
several texts time and I'm taking all of
them yeah and there was still late one
is a question I think it's like manatees
do you think what you're doing is
intrinsic to what works on scientific
papers or do you think it could be
expanded across wide range of
disciplines and also to success but that
I know that certainly some submissive
little some journals you have to do
keywords to specify so do you think you
could also use it to look see it's
appropriate keywords are actually being
used or if the keywords are presenting a
either an unhelpful or a completely
misleading idea of what the article is
ok so for the question of if it can be
used in other area well I hope it could
be used in other area my assumption at
first was for well this kind of science
that some terms will be more interesting
that others and that's why I wanted to
clean it as much as possible but i guess
that may not be the right way to go and
maybe I should stop the trying to clean
and keep really scientific terms and
just keep the wall of the article so in
this way I think it should be
reproducible with other area and the
second question was oh yeah the QR so
well that was one of the idea from the
start because when you are doing a
search you can even receive like email
alerts for certain topics but what if
it's not classified properly and then
you are missing it so I'm hoping like
that's what I would like it to be but
the problem is here i'm relying on some
tags already because i cannot like read
myself or have someone for example from
humanities actually look at the article
to classify it will be like too much of
so i'm a bit in this i have to rely on a
produce tag so maybe
if I use it to read tag maybe it will be
different from website to website as
well but i'm not sure i can see what is
the right tag in the lsi uh oh no keep
taking notes no not at all so that's so
at my company we mostly don't use Python
but when I came in there was a script
for NLP done by a contractor that I had
to refactor and that's how I actually so
oh that's how we can get like topics and
it was using GF IDF and sigh so no I
didn't know do you think it will be more
relevant to this kind of o-mai undecided
man you're using is it looks impart to
our relevance walls together MDA
label topics distributors what the work
okay so alleviate some of the ambulance
correlate together topics with an Lda
you can have a distribution over all the
various topics community so that maybe
I'm problems in a particular belongs to
you sighs cell biology you have a
distribution about what you want to go
on to do so is not okay yeah I don't
know that's a good thing to test I guess
thank you